würdest du eher ein ungetoastetes Toast
mit Käse essen oder ein Grill cheese
Sandwich weil das ist verdammt lecker
und es könnte einfacher nicht sein wir
brauchen zwei Scheiben Toast eine
Scheibe Cheddar eine Scheibe American
cheese und Butter die Butter nehmen wir
und streichen Sie am besten sollte die
schon Raumtemperatur haben auf unserem
Toast aus wichtig ist dass man wirklich
gleichmäßig die Butter verteilt dann
legen wir die erste Scheibe mit der
Butterseite nach unten in die Pfanne die
ist schon vorgeheizt das nächste kommt
unser chedder und ganz wichtig damit das
ganze schön zieht American cheese jetzt
kommt der Deckel drauf und wir lassen
das Ganze langsam aber sicher goldbraun
werden lasst euch ein bisschen von eurer
Nase leiten und nach ein paar Minuten
sollte es auf der einen Seite so
aussehen ein wunderschönes goldgelb und
fertig ist unser perfektes grinchies
Sandwich alles was wir jetzt noch
brauchen ist ein blockbrett um das ganze
zu schneiden funktioniert natürlich auch
mit jedem anderen aber Block ich meine
eigenen check mal aus und fertig ist
unser Grill cheese Sandwich eine Frage
bleibt